billionaire and free speech warrior elon
musk has bought twitter but what happens
next he's joked on the platform that
he'll be buying coca-cola to put cocaine
back in he'll make the platform maximum
fun he says but responding to a meme
admitted he can't make miracles happen
and fix all the ice cream machines in
mcdonald's
joking aside ultimately he says he wants
twitter to be politically neutral which
effectively means upsetting the far
right and the far left equally well
hurrah to that but how will he do it and
can he do it i'm joined now by sky news
australia presenter erin mullen and
co-founder of wikipedia jimmy wells
welcome to both of you i'll be starting
with you erin uh over there in australia
um
my first reaction when i heard this and
i'm a twitter shareholder sort of vested
interest in it not collapsing my first
reaction was good because elon musk is a
maverick billionaire genius but he
believes passionately in free speech
isn't it bizarre that you look at
someone who's spending 44 billion
dollars to buy an asset and that the
selling line the mission statement so to
speak is i just want to make everyone
absolutely miserable that is so twitter
it is so brilliant
it's like
can he do it i don't know is he the
right person i don't know not many other
people have the kind of money that he
has to do it i like some of the things
that he's talking about at this stage it
is really all head no beer there's not
much detail on how he'll actually try
and achieve all the things he's saying
but i think authenticating humans is a
great start we know that the bots the
span the fake accounts are really where
the the cesspit of twitter erupts so i
think that's a wonderful thing the town
square as well i think is a great
concept but he's also got to realize
that town squares even archaically are
regulated so it can't just be an
absolute free-for-all you need you need
rules you need regulations you need free
speech absolutely but he needs to also
remove the hypocrisy which i think he's
doing yeah and you say obviously donald
trump is banned yet a bloke committing
genocide is uh is still on the platform
exactly that's the hypocrisy which has
to be eliminated and you've done some
great work in going after trolls vicious
trolls and getting them made properly
accountable which is one of the things
elon musk says he'll do did you be
wealthy he said he's going to create a
situation where you've got to be
identifiable to be on the platform and
and all of that you though are very
skeptical about musk being an effective
owner of twitter why
yeah i mean i think it's a couple of
things so first of all i mean you know
the the one of the most famous and
incredibly talented twitter trolls in
history takes over twitter what could
possibly go wrong um but when we look at
his his promises about free speech okay
good but it's not really clear what that
means this idea of identifying everyone
on the platform though that's going to
be very very hard and it does raise a
lot of really complicated questions
people are using twitter
as a support group mechanism
they're talking to people in in lots of
ways that aren't huge and in the public
guy with millions of followers
and i think that's a very difficult
thing to say oh let's not have that
anymore i mean it's very hard isn't it
to regulate any of these things properly
like i mean on your platform for example
wikipedia my eldest son is actually here
tonight to watch the show and he
he was used to several years long battle
with some
somebody out there who kept changing my
wikipedia entry on a tiny point a
factual point to make me the youngest of
four children when i'm the oldest which
meant every profile that ever occurred
about me had me the youngest of four
kids and every time my son edited it
back whoever this was changed it back
again oh dear how do you that's a it's a
little trivial thing it doesn't really
matter but all it meant was that when
people looked at wikipedia on my site
they just got a wrong piece of
information every time how and that's
just a small thing on wikipedia how does
elon musk you think have any kind of
regulatory system which allows free
speech that doesn't allow the kind of
cesspit stuff that we see all day long
well so one of the things about
wikipedia is like our job is actually a
lot easier we we don't say we're a wide
open free speech platform we say we're
an encyclopedia you need reliable
sources i imagine in your case if
profiles said it then suddenly there's a
bunch of sources that maybe got it from
us and then they print it and we think
of the journalists or the sources we
call it cytogenesis it's sort of a
circular thing that can happen but in
general we don't allow people to come on
and just sort of say whatever random
thing is on their mind and when you do
then you're really into this area of uh
really complicated questions about
freedom of expression uh you know how do
you determine what's just a snarky
comment versus what's actually abusive
okay there aren't easy answers no it's
none of this is easy i don't think at
all but i do aaron i come back to my
initial gut feeling about elon musk is
that i like his basic principle position
that he wants to enrage the far left and
the far right equally because he wants
them all to basically be put back in
their box and allow the vast majority of
people who are reasonably not extreme at
all um to have a proper debate in
conversation again
and not feel that they're being hindered
or censored
absolutely and that's what we've managed
to do here in australia with the new
laws that we have and look the threshold
for what would be considered criminal
threatening harassment is incredibly
high it's akin to that of the criminal
code and and that's what you need in a
space like twitter you want robust
debate you want people to be able to
disagree you want differences of opinion
regardless of what side of politics
you're from regardless of where you're
from in the world but you cannot have a
free-for-all platform where people are
allowed to threaten to rape other
people's children you spoke to sharon
osborne and you look at the damage
that's done so i would like elon musk to
not just look at at advocating for free
speech which i know it's a mountain that
you want to die on and not not want to
but that you would you'd be willing to
it's so important but he needs to
eradicate the crap that has made twitter
just a vile platform well he does by the
way and by the way aaron i've been on
twitter since august last year and
happiest i've been well it's not just
twitter i mean on instagram you know
i've got a police case going through now
with somebody somebody made specific
death threats to one of my children uh
on on his instagram page it was in the
in the sort of period of all that meghan
markle thing on the morning show and
that's still going through the wheels of
justice because i just thought you not
i'm not having that even someone makes
everything and that's why the laws in
australia are so good and they're world
first is because they cover everything
it's not about one platform doing
something specifically these are laws
that cover every single social media
platform and it makes the online world
safer and better for everyone erin gotta
leave it there great to talk to you come
back soon please jimmy thank you so much
as well i'm a huge fan of wikipedia by
the
way
despite my my fact that i am actually
the oldest actually jimmy could you
change my photo and my wiki feed rating
is low too we'll take a look none of us
could be on tv without wikipedia let's
be honest jimmy thank you great to talk
to you both